I don't know so much time trying to be
beautiful let's be realistic he'll
probably turn out just cute what are you
looking to get done I want green lips
really soft and natural looking she made
me look like a damn dog what's wrong
with your head
I got a permanent she did it that way
I'm perfect why do they look so much
what do you mean us but I killed those
huncles Jim I think you have a low sex
drive you know I just put on my
hairpiece we need help
I'm an ad on a board we'll end up with a
serial killer who here is afraid of
their family well I'm afraid to my
wife's gonna get drunk and embarrass me
in public again mm I think of family
it's like a car you can wax it or you
can let it stay 35 sometimes you're
surrounded
you just gotta shoot your way out this
one there we go cat stance kick like a
cat this is our chance we can finally
beat those girls
use your willpower conquer your fears
your daddy wears a wig I didn't ever yes
you did I was there remember I am the
child and you were the adult
doing your mother's problem is she
doesn't know jack all about how the
world works we're a family don't just
give up you want about me where's your
courage I've got plenty of courage
where's your courage is my middle name
Jean if you were a magazine I would buy
a subscription I want to be a subscriber
you
you